Energy and data are the major
currencies of our lives today.
Over the last couple of decades,
we've seen data going from being
wired to becoming wireless.
And this has helped democratize
access to information.
Can we do the same thing with energy?
Can we send energy when we want,
where we want and as much as we want
and in the process,
eliminate the last wire?
If we could do this,
the possibilities would be endless.
From Earth to space.
I'd like to tell you about our dream
of wireless energy transfer today.
It starts with something
we are all familiar with -- waves.
So waves are very essential to our lives.
You can hear this talk
because of acoustic waves.
You can see this talk
because of a certain kind
of electromagnetic waves, called light.
And the odds are, if you're
watching it on the internet,
you're using some sort
of wireless connectivity
that relies on wireless and RF waves.
If you have two waves
that have the same frequency
and are going up and down
and they come together
at some point in space,
they will add and make a wave
that's twice the height
but carries four times the energy.
Now, if the same two waves come together
at some other place in space,
but one is running half a period late,
they cancel
and you get very little energy,
practically no energy.
This is the basis for a process
that has been known for a long time.
It's called interference.
The idea here is that if you go
and sit at the edge of a pond
and take both hands
and put them in the water
and move them up and down,
each hand makes a wave.
But because of the interaction
of these waves,
there will be some directions
where you get more energy
and there are some directions
that you will get less.
Can we make it go only in one direction?
Well, you need more hands.
And they have to go
perfectly synchronized.
But if you do that,
what happens is that most of your energy
starts traveling straight down.
Now, this is a remarkable thing
because if you think about each one
of those little hands,
each one of those little sources,
they would send energy all over the place.
But when they work together,
the result is that the energy
is going mostly in one direction.
Now, if the timing was the reason
for this happening,
maybe we can play with it.
Maybe we can mess with it
and see what happens.
So what if each one of these sources
goes a little bit after
the one next to it?
So in that case,
what happens is that these waves
start going in different directions,
and you can change that direction
purely by controlling timing
and nothing else.
Now, this makes it possible
to change this direction
without any mechanical movement.
So it can be almost instantaneous.
You can go even further.
You can think about creating
a magnifying glass.
A focusing system,
where you can actually send the energy,
most of it, close to 90 percent of it,
in one focal point.
But again, since
you're controlling the timing,
you can create different focal points,
and you can send it to them.
And this is the basis
for wireless energy transfer.
It's as if you have an army of ants
that are working
in perfect synchronization.
And each one of them contributes
a little bit of energy.
But as a whole, they send it
to the right place.
Now,
obviously here, timing is everything,
like life and comedy.
(Laughter)
So we’ve taken this concept,
and we've built these electronic chips,
integrated circuits,
that each one of them generates
a little bit of power.
But again, as a group, they are designed
to work in perfect synchronization
and drive these little antennas
that transmit the energy.
Now this army of ants,
or army of antennas,
is working together to create
those focal points of energy.
And what I will show you next
is some examples
of how that actually operates.
So what you have here, for example,
is a generator unit that's sending power
wirelessly to the two receivers.
And here the point is to see
how well-defined these focal points are.
That LED panel basically is receiving
that power and showing it.
So you can see energy is going only
where it needs to go and nowhere else.
You can take this and put
one of these generators
on the ceiling of your conference room
or your living room
and transmit energy
to various devices that need energy.
Now this generator on the ceiling
is going to power a light bulb.
Now, as we move the light bulb,
what happens is that you see
that there's no energy
in the new location,
but the system finds it, tracks it
and sends it to the new location.
And you can see that it dynamically
tracks it back and forth.
You can use this to send energy
to one light bulb
or to the next one
or to both of them at the same time.
Now you can use something like this,
for example, to power a drone.
This is a battery-less drone
that's being purely powered
by that generator
facing up from the bottom.
And it can also use the same tracking
approach to track the drone.
So now that we know that we can
send energy wirelessly,
the question is, how far can we go?
Really, how far can we go?
Could we put photovoltaics in space,
solar panels in space,
and collect the energy
and send that wirelessly to Earth?
This is not a new idea.
The first time it was mentioned,
it was in a short science-fiction story
by Isaac Asimov from 1941.
And what I love about this story is that
it's about a self-conscious robot.
And the humans describing this idea
to the self-conscious robot,
after which the robot says,
"Do you expect me to believe
such a far-fetched, crazy notion?
What do you take me for?"
The first question almost
always asked is that,
“Why do you want to put
your solar panels in space?
Why don’t you put them up
in the desert and be done with it?” Right?
A few reasons.
First is that in space you get
about eight times more energy
because you don't have day and night,
you don't have clouds,
you don't have seasons,
and you don't have
the atmospheric absorption.
Also, now that you have this ability
to send energy where you want
and when you want dynamically,
you can imagine that you have
dispatchable power.
On top of that,
it's an always-available power.
This can be used for a place, for example,
let's say an island hit by a hurricane
where there’s no power.
Or a city in war zone
where the power infrastructure
is being constantly attacked.
You can think about using
this to send power
to a remote village in sub-Saharan Africa
where there is no infrastructure
for power transmission.
And that way democratize
the access to energy.
Or send it somewhere
above the Arctic circle.
So all of these things are great.
But the question is,
if it has been known for such a long time
and it's such a great thing,
why hasn't it been done so far?
The main reason is that the way
it has been envisioned before,
they've been thinking
about it as a big elephant.
If you're thinking about putting
big solar panels in space,
collecting the power,
generating a lot of energy,
and then putting it into a massive
parabolic dish antenna
and sending it to a fixed
location on Earth.
Sending things to space is expensive.
You pay dollars --
and that's plural -- per gram.
The other problem is that even
if you could afford it,
assembly of something like this in space
is still beyond the capabilities
that we have today.
So we came up with a very
different approach
where we took our generators
and turned them into flexible,
fabric-like structures.
We are utilizing the amazing
power of electronics,
integrated electronics
and flexible electronics,
to make this very lightweight,
flexible, fabric-like structures
that you can roll and pack.
And this allows you to have these
satellites packed for launch
and deployed in space,
where each one of these units
would be about several tens
of meters on the side.
And then you can pack
a whole bunch of them
and create a constellation of them
that flies in space
and forms your power station
to send green energy to Earth.
This will be flying in formation
around the Earth.
Obviously, this is not
the size of the planet
because we're talking about a kilometer
across for the whole whole constellation
and the planet is a little bit
larger than a kilometer.
We've been developing,
as a proof of concept,
technology demonstrator,
and this is called Maple,
which demonstrates the power
of flexible structures
and electronic circuitry
to generate and transmit power in space.
We integrated that with two other
technology demonstrators
for deployable structures
and photovoltaics
that were developed by three teams,
led by myself and two of my colleagues.
And we integrated into a satellite
that was launched recently.
And the purpose of this experiment
has been to demonstrate
the power transfer,
wireless power transfer in space.
Now that brings me back
to the promise of wireless energy transfer
and what it could mean for us.
I believe this technology
is too compelling to go away.
And I believe it's bound to appear
in our lives in one form or another.
And that is something to look forward to.
Thank you.
(Applause)